do you really have to spend 250 dollars
to get good wireless earbuds well
earphone doesn't think so and a lot of
reviewers don't as well this is the
earphone Air Pro 3 their latest update
and people love these not only because
their MSRP is eighty dollars compared to
250. that's a massive difference but
because they are packed with really
impressive specs and good audio quality
So today we're doing a David versus
Goliath battle and seeing how the Air
Pro 3 stack up to the flagship airpods
Pro 2. not only that we actually just
updated our setup and we have these
binaural microphone setups you guys will
actually hear exactly what I hear when
I'm comparing them now a lot of earbud
companies reach out to us wanting us to
cover their earbuds but when earphone
reached out we looked at the specs in
the user reviews it was quite quite
impressive let's go ahead and get this
thing out of the box here even though
these are 80 bucks MSRP if you guys use
our coupon code you can actually get it
for 56. 30 off which is an insane deal
and these also use Qualcomm technology
for a lot of the features that they use
Bluetooth 5.3 ipx water resistance and
the battery life is very impressive we
have a combined 45 hours and then nine
hours for the buds themselves and I
wanted to make sure this is accurate so
I looked at some reviews online where
somebody tested they got six and a half
hours with these earbuds which is really
good of course that depends on your
volume type stuff like that and as you
guys could see the case is larger than
the airpods Pro 2 case it is also
thicker but they're definitely packing
in more battery inside of there of
course both of these have wired charging
we have USBC on the ear fun and they
both have wireless charging as well
which is nice because some of the lower
priced wireless earbuds don't have that
feature now opening them up you guys
could see that these are top loading the
Air Pro 3s also have a stemmed design
just like the airpod pros too but they
are a little bit longer now as far as
comfort the airpod pros 2 are very
comfortable in your ears so let's take
these out and try out the ear funs the
tips that came with them are a perfect
size for me I didn't have to swap those
and with these updated models the stem
actually sits a little bit further from
your face giving you a little bit more
room which is nice but with the silken
ear tips um the Comfort feels good as
well they don't have the little valves
that the airpods pros to do to relieve
some of that pressure but I don't feel
the bulb around and that part is nice
and as far as the controls these use tap
controls whereas the earpod pros too
they have that little click where you
can squeeze it and you get that feedback
now you pair these just like any other
bluetooth earbuds so you're not going to
get the quick little pop-up like you do
on airpods but earphone does have their
own app and Bam they are connected and
here you guys can see that we have the
battery life for the earbuds and the
case you can swap between your modes we
have some other settings here and the
first thing that I want to test out is
the active noise cancellation I have a
video open up right here with loud
airplane noise let's start with the
airpods pro 2. we know these do a killer
job
and Bam pretty much all that low end
went away I do still hear some of that
high end but these do great now let's go
ahead and take these out let's try out
the Air Pro 3s okay
they sound pretty good
um the high end I actually hear a little
bit more with the Air Pro 3s but the low
end is actually surprisingly similar and
once again they are using Qualcomm
technology for some of that processing
and the microphones so just listen to
these back and forth with the airpods a
few times just with our ambient room
noise we have an HVAC system that's
always on and you hear that hum going
and these actually block the same amount
as the airpods Pro 2 and this kind of an
office environment with that vent being
right above there so in an airplane
environment they are a little bit worse
but in this environment they are the
same and I'm honestly really impressed
with these I've listened some earbuds
that are around the 120 Mark that have
active noise cancellation and these
actually sound better and user reviews
online I mentioned that as well and I
want to test out the Ambient sound mode
or the transparency modes right now I am
a normal
let's switch to ambient all right Vadim
go ahead and say something
you sound pretty good I sound a little
bit weird like hearing my voice it
doesn't sound very natural but go ahead
and say something again
here I sound kind of muted but you sound
fairly natural you don't sound nasally
or anything like that but let's switch
to these we know the airpods Pro 2 are
the gold standard
for transparency mode all right go ahead
and say something again how do I sign
with those you sound similar I get a
little bit more highs in your voice a
little bit more uh volume
and then for my own voice I don't sound
Perfectly Natural but definitely more
natural than these now I think the next
thing will be to test out the
microphones and these have six mics
built in this is a microphone quality
using Apple's airpods Pro 2. and this is
the microphone quality using the
earphone Air Pro 3. so let me know down
in the comments what you thought about
the microphone quality and now it is
time to compare sound quality we're
gonna get out these fancy ear
microphones and I'm gonna be listening
to the tracks and what you guys are
going to hear and see is our recording
using these which stimulate real ears so
you guys can actually hear the
difference for yourselves and we're
going to start out with an electronic
track
[Music]
New Year bring me back
all right guys I am pleasantly
pleasantly surprised these sound better
than 150 earbuds that we have tested
here on the channel uh the bass is
heavier than the airpods Pro 2 but of
course you can EQ that out maybe I'll do
that for the next track I'll just EQ it
down a little bit but it doesn't sound
bad the bass is Rich it's not boomy it's
deep and the vocals they sound nice and
smooth and I think the highs might be a
little bit less sharp than the airpods
Pro 2 but I'm honestly shocked I thought
the difference would be really big
between these two earbuds so that was
actually a pleasant surprise so let me
go here into the EQ looks like there are
some presets right here but I'm gonna
drop the bass down just a tiny bit and
maybe push up
the highs here just a little bit as well
[Music]
once again I'm very impressed with the
sound I think I could turn the bass down
a little bit more in the settings
because with this track I was a little
bit bass heavy but these sound fantastic
now let's switch to our last song which
is a rock track
[Music]
oh
and that was the last track once again I
am impressed now when I start listening
to that I went into the EQ and you can
actually use the sliders live while
you're listening to it and it adjusts it
whereas with some earbuds you have to
hit save and so it's a longer process so
this is the final EQ that I landed on
and they sounded surprisingly close to
the airpods now the airpods the
soundstage is wider I have them tuned
with Apple's tunability in there so
they're definitely better but these are
surprisingly close and once again I've
listened to ear earbuds that are 150
maybe even more that sound similar or
worse so I would say the sound quality
wise you're in that 175 200 range once
you EQ them like this so I'm honestly
very very surprised with these now I
know what to recommend to people that
need a pair of earbuds and they don't
want to spend a whole lot of money
another cool thing is these have
multi-point connections so you can
connect the two devices at one time time
where more expensive ones still lack
that feature of course the airpods have
find my capability they have the speaker
built in so that is really nice if
you're using the iOS ecosystem but you
guys let me know what you think what you
guys heard the sound comparison some of
the other comparisons are these a great
pair of earbuds for 56 bucks right with
our coupon code 56 bucks I think it's an
incredible incredible value you guys
could check it out using the link down
in the video description below go ahead
and click that Circle above to subscribe
and check out one of those great videos
right over there this has been Max and
I'll see you in the next video
[Music]
thank you